it's definitely been like opening up an
old wound you know we see Gigi fleeing
in a wedding dress we see her falling in
the mud yelling how dare you - Damien I
mean breakdown what happened
we had already gone through so much you
know meeting without seeing each other
and then getting used to each other in
person a lot of fears happened leading
up to that point where you know
insecurities got brought up and a lot of
doubts surfaced so I think I came to a
point where you know I had seen how he
reacted with me I you know felt
comfortable with him and just kind of
wanted to give myself over to him in a
way that he knew how and and that was
just that was my answer he told me that
he didn't know what he was gonna say up
until the moment that he saw me and it's
just it's just hard when you've you're
in your wedding dress in front of all
your friends and family and you know I
respect his decision and I understand
why you know he did the way he said what
he did so that we could have a true
healthy relationship because marriage
was putting a lot of pressure on us but
it was just hard you know you're you're
vulnerable like at your most vulnerable
state and I just wanted to kind of just
pretend it didn't happen and I finally
was able to just run and and that's what
I did because the entire time you know I
was facing my fears couldn't not talk
about things because I was gonna share
my life with this person and I just I
needed some time to myself I mean it was
like almost like a movie moment but it
was like happening in your real life you
know that's exactly how it was um it was
just very surreal I couldn't believe
that it was happening but I just
it felt right to me I just wanted to
again just be with myself and just
like kind of replay things or just like
hold myself and um I didn't think
anybody was following me and which is
like naive to think at this point you
know I thought okay I did the wedding
I'm done but no that was not the case so
I just reacted naturally it was hard it
was really hard it was uh it wasn't my
intention to hurt her I mean it was our
plans to you know no matter what to sort
of walk away from this together and I
see how the decision embarrassed her and
you know it wasn't front of her family
and friends and that's something I wish
I could take away from her every day I
didn't ever want to have to go through
that experience that so it broke my
heart it was honestly one of the hardest
decisions I ever made but we had talked
about it and she didn't believe in
traditional marriage like in the sense
of feeling like we're trapped by a
document that says you know oh we got to
do this because when you get into
marriage you move in together you collab
on finances then you're ready to start a
family there's all these senses that
come with the word marriage and with us
having this date rushing up on it you
know when I got up there it was just
like is this right for us can we be
stronger outside of here do any more
time to be best friends first because we
had already faced so many challenges as
you guys saw and just a few pieces of
our relationship on the show right so I
mean I made the decision I did and it
was because I wanted to make sure that
marriage is forever like in a sense of
maturity had you know this thing with
her parents where they were divorced and
that was really hard on her growing up I
didn't want that to happen again I
wanted to make sure we were a hundred
percent in it and there weren't no
outside factors deciding upon that truly
just of us so it was it was hard it was
very hard and I wouldn't ask her I just
couldn't find her yeah yeah
Elspeth it really was like it was like
the drama the movie moment but I mean
how challenging is it for you guys
because you know in a normal
relationship you go through these
hurdles and then you don't have to
rewatch them and now you guys are kind
of reliving these moments so what's
what's that been like for you guys I
mean it's definitely been like opening
up an old vent
you know it sure in the means the tweets
and everyone has something to say about
every single couple how do you guys feel
about how you've been portrayed and kind
of what people have been saying and is
there anything you want to clear the air
about I'd say overall the show didn't
show enough of our story especially in
the beginning of how our connection
really built we had some really
beautiful moments that were never
portrayed and even though we had some
really harsh drugged-out fights that you
guys saw we had really beautiful moments
too so you know it sucks um you know
I've gotten different things from like I
like he's gas lighting which I had to
look that up and it was but it's like
you know it's manipulation to make
somebody else seem angry or crazy and
you know me and her have done a lot of
talking and discussing and there were
points where you know we pushed each
other and it did call drop calls
breaking points and something I was back
on and I'm not super proud of because I
never had that intention my intention
was solely like I love this girl I'll do
whatever it takes to show her I'm she's
she's what I want in a woman yeah so
there was there was no manipulative
meaning on either one of our hands
towards each other it was purely just
something new in a very condensed amount
of time and you're you're learning each
other's entire lives and a month I'm not
gonna have and and there's a lot of
stress bondage that I don't think people
understand or see they just see a show
put together or not emotions and
people's lives the lives that were
affected behind all of it so because of
the pause in the experiment where you
guys couldn't actually see each other do
you guys think if you met at a bar ran
into each other in Atlanta so you guys
would have started dating organically no
I don't think so I don't think so
I mean I wouldn't usually I would have
had that you know that little
superficial take where I walked in and
out of like no no that's my type and
especially I definitely won't talk to
her but I think you know if we didn't
get to know each other on the emotional
connection that we did physically I
think it still would have been never
been an attraction there for sure and I
just I think we would have let out
different parts too early that you
normally do in a relationship then
really getting to the root of who you
are and what kind of personality you are
meeting you cry a lot you know because I
am I'm an emotional guy big guy
yeah but I mean you know in this world
you like some people like oh man let you
know let you let you jump and crap no
it's it's uh it's okay guys to cry okay
you can be a man to be emotional that's
totally normal
so we're we accepted all these things
and it's just you know I think overall
it it would have been hard doing it
without this experience just to wrap it
up is there anything about your guys
relationship that you want people to
know that you think what was missed on
the show I think that I don't know some
people catch it but I think a lot of
people don't know help like funny we are
and just like how spontaneous we both
can be and they showed that a little bit
but like the way that we just kind of
come to terms is just really just really
refreshing we're so different you can
honestly like we have so much fun with
each other and it's been it's been a
really great just like growing
experience to go with someone to go it
through it with someone that just like
knows me in and out like to my core like
I felt like Damian was reading my mind
throughout like this whole experience
and I just you can't make that up yeah
and I feel like you know we did miss a
good bit of our story in the pods it was
there was so many beautiful moments that
really led us so you saw a lot of you
know marks and Barnett's and you know
cam like there there are sort of
frontline stories but a lot of the
things that
where we were or some just beautifully
like she said mind-reading moments like
it wasn't staged like I couldn't express
people were like I think you guys are
doing the same thing on each side he
never seeing each other yeah it'd be
like you like the way that you guys move
in the way that you say things like you
guys are mirroring each other and a
sixth sense is the perfect word it's
like a sixth sense that you have and
when the connections are real it's like
every day you're like I just want to
hear that voice again every night I went
to bed I was like I just I'm getting
through these other days just so I can
hear her voice again and it's crazy
right but it's it it's so it's such an a
I would say beautiful experience to get
enough money for who they are on the
inside then what they look like it was
like an out-of-body experience literally
an experiment to its core
[Music]